-Well, I guess
all's well that ends --
-It's them over there.
-[Bleep]
Okay, this piazza is famously
full of pigeons.
We run straight at them,
and when they take flight,
they'll hide us in a canopy
of wings and feathers.
-Sounds good.
Let's go.
[ Crunching ]
-They're not flying.
-Why won't they fly?
-We're just crunching them.
-I can hear their tiny,
brittle bones beneath my feet.
-Oh, God.
I think I just curbed one.
Are we going to hell for this?
-I have now killed
like 4,000 pigeons.
-I will never not feel them
under my feet.
-And we're leaving a perfect
pigeon carcass path
for the Caesars to follow.
-It's disgusting
and hurting our cause.
[ Laughter ]
-We're back with Andy Samberg.
That was a clip from "Digman!"
This is very exciting.
I've watched the first
couple of episodes.
You play an archeologist?
-I do.
-Also known as an arky.
That's what they call
each other in the show.
-Yes. Ad nauseam.
-And this is a --
kind of a Nick Cage voice.
Is that a safe assumption?
-I would say it was birthed
from my Nick Cage impression.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, and then
now has become its own
entire world, which is fun.
-It's really fun.
This show is full of jokes,
which I know is something
you take very seriously.
-Thank you for saying that.
[ Laughter ]
-And a really fun cast.
A lot of our friends are in it,
and that must be
just so much fun, as well.
-It's a treat and a delight,
and I hope everyone on earth,
literally every person
on earth, watches it.
-Yeah.
It's also --
It's on Comedy Central,
and it's really fun
because I feel like
at some point
the rules just changed
and it's so -- the language
is so delightfully filthy.
-Yes.
Well, it's a lot like --
The rules have changed
in the world, you know.
-Oh, wow,
This is so deep.
-[ Groans ]
Honestly, I put a lot of energy
in the first segment,
and I just ran out of gas.
[ Laughter ]
Full -- Just hit the wall.
Like, I don't know, man.
My kids woke up at like 4:00.
-Your kids don't live
in New York.
-No, no.
I slept alone last night.
[ Laughter ]
Whoo!
It was nice, too.
-Yeah, great.
-Yeah, I got
that good hotel blanket.
-You -- There was an article
about you in "The New Yorker."
And one of the exciting things
about "The New Yorker"
is they do a little bit of art,
a cartoon, if you will.
-Yes, they do
the caricature of you,
which going in I knew I was
gonna have feelings about.
But you're also just like --
But it's an honor
'cause it's "The New Yorker,"
so I did get mine.
-And how do you feel about it?
-I feel interesting.
-Okay. That's what
"The New Yorker" came up with.
Now, you saw this, though,
and you actually thought
there was somebody --
It made you think -- Not --
It didn't look like somebody.
-No, it immediately
made me think,
"This is a person Fred has,
like, a voice for."
Fred, have you seen it?
Do you see this guy?
-I see.
-Okay.
-[Dopey voice]
Uh, you guys open?
[ Laughter ]
-That was the voice.
That was the voice.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"You guys open?"
-Yeah.
-One more, Fred. One more.
-It says you close at 5:00.
[ Normal voice ]
Because of the jaw.
There's, like, a --
[ Laughter ]
-It's the jacket that really
makes it that guy.
-Yeah.
Alright, buddy, well, what
a delight to have you here.
-Always a treat. Love you.
-Thank you so much.
It's very nice to know that
if anything should happen to me,
God forbid, the show will be
in safe hands.
-Thank you so much.
Yes, I'll be ready and willing.
Again, I got nothing left.
I'm truly gonna walk offstage
and pass out on the floor.
-Andy Samberg, everybody.
"Digman!" is so funny.
It airs Wednesday nights
at 10:30
right after "South Park"
on Comedy Central.